bienvenue à tous sur les chaînes
parlementaires seller de par le web de
45 minutes pour faire le tour de l'actu
politique parlementaire mojo katia et
cette semaine dans l'actualité la france
réagit après l'assassinât der beek
gourdel l'otage français et l'exécuter
en algérie drapeaux en berne françois
hollande demande l'union sacrée dans le
pays
l'intervention des forces françaises en
irak commence à diviser notamment à
droite des voix s'élèvent également pour
frapper en syrie l'actualité politique
avec le retour de nicolas sarkozy qui a
tenu son ultime de rentrer à lambersart
dans le nord l'ancien président de la
république a appelé à des primaires à
droite pour désigner le candidat à
l'élection de 2017
nous parlerons de m'expliquer ce qui est
arrivé chez nous les entreprises
américaines proposent des films et
séries tv en illimité sur internet
menace ou chance pour la france
on en reparlera à la fin de mission et
c'est frédéric lefebvre qui est avec
nous cette semaine
bonjour ou ancien ministre député ump
vous représenter les français établis
hors de france ceux qui vivent en
amérique du nord et vous avez fait
partie du cercle rapproché de nicolas
sarkozy on n'en parlera mais d'abord
c'est la route c'est la routine dans
cette émission on a demandé à quelques
uns de vos collègues à l'assemblée ce
qu'il pensait de vous écouter
c'est un très bon collègue très
sympathique aujourd'hui député des
français de l'étranger
je pense que c'est une mission qui nous
va très bien aujourd'hui je suis très
heureuse de frédéric effet puis je suis
son ami en même temps donc voilà il a
été au service d'un homme et il s'est
aperçu parfois qu'il vaut mieux être
aussi parfois être au service de ses
convictions
zadig et voltaire eh ben je pense que
son lit aux a dit que voltaire est très
bon et qu'il aura un succès durable dans
le temps alors frédéric lefebvre voilà
pour ces réactions vous allez au service
d'un homme
et maintenant vous êtes au service de
vos convictions mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé où est passé le frédéric lefebvre
qu'on connaissait tuer vous savez
surtout au service des français
en parlant de livres j'ai sorti un livre
qui s'appelle vous êtes prioritaire
ceux ci vivent de 58 pages on signale un
format original un livre numérique ça
veut dire disponible par téléchargement
et publié par un l'éditeur
franco-américain
mais c'est assez français que je
m'adresse et c'est pour ces français que
je me suis engagé en politique et je
crois que c'est ça l'essentiel
je raconte un certain nombre et donc
changé vous mais vous savez je raconte
dans ce livre plusieurs choses d'abord
je pense que quand on fait de la
politique
enfin qu'on n'a pas été au gouvernement
quand on n'a pas eu la responsabilité de
gouverner et et d'une partie de la
politique de son pays
on n'est pas en mesure d'être un vrai
homme politique je dirais ministre n'a
pas été à dole politique c'est ce que
voulait dire
enfin on est toujours un homme politique
mais on n'est pas en tout cas on n'a pas
la même approche la même responsabilité
par rapport aux politiques publiques et
aux françaises eric rey et de surcroît
j'ai raconté aussi une part de ma vie
puisque j'ai tutoyé la mort et je pense
que chaque personne qui tutoie la mort
vit une manière différente ensuite
d'embrasser la vie avec une énergie
différente et je crois que se concentrer
sur l'essentiel ancien c'est quoi pour
vous l'essentiel ce sont les français si
si je me suis engagé en politique que si
jeune si je
j'y mets ma passion j'ai aimé mon
énergie c'est d'abord parce que je veux
servir les français je veux changer mon
pays c'est ça aujourd'hui qui animent
mon action que vous ne ferai plus jamais
de la politique comme avant le cogneur
reconnaissait qu'il décocher des flèches
à tout bout de champ vous savez d'abord
j'ai il faut vous il ya une vraie
continuité parce que j'ai dénoncé quand
j'étais porte parole de ma famille
politique
les attaques incessantes contre nicolas
sarkozy qui était président de la
république contre le gouvernement et on
voit d'ailleurs la situation dans
laquelle est aujourd'hui l'actuelle
majorité
1préparer à la gouvernance alors voilà
on retrouve non les jeux et je dénonce
avec la même force aujourd'hui
si vous écoutez ce que je dis comme
l'opposition passe son temps à détruire
le président de la république actuel
comme cela mais non il faut construire
et donc ce que je dénonçais à l'époque
quand je riposter aux attaques
je le dénonce avec la même force
aujourd'hui parce que je pense que notre
pays nos compatriotes
les artisans les commerçants les
entrepreneurs les salariés qui sont dans
des entreprises en difficulté
vous croyez qu'ils peuvent attendre 2017
vous croyez que ces salariés
aujourd'hui ils peuvent accepter les
joutes politiciennes permanente qui
n'ont aucun sens et aucun intérêt à
aller on va partir sur tout bien sûr
vous allez me donner toute votre vérité
sur cette semaine écoulée elle a eu une
actualité on commence par un indice et
le retour
un petit peu plus de 8 millions de
téléspectateurs étaient devant leur
écran pour regarder l'interview de
nicolas sarkozy pendant à peu près 40
minutes pour autant at il convaincu les
français on voit cela avec frau sow
goulens nicolas sarkozy a marqué son
grand retour dimanche sur la scène
médiatique
candidat à la présidence de l'ump en
novembre l'ex président veut réformer le
parti de fond en comble en seulement
trois mois
je suis venu pour créer les conditions
d'une alternative crédible qui rassemble
des français bien au delà des clivages
habituels droite gauche centre droite
écologistes libéraux qui n'ont plus
aucun sens sur le plateau de france 2
l'ancien chef de l'état affirme
également avoir honte de la politique
menée par le gouvernement à l'égard de
l'allemagne
quant à 2017 nicolas sarkozy s'est
défendu d'y penser
lui qui sait que sur son chemin il
trouvera notamment françois fillon
candidat aux primaires en 2016 ainsi
qu'alain juppé alain juppé j'ai connu où
j'avais 20 ans c'est un partenaire et un
ami est un compagnon
c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai même de
l'autre bien sûr et j'aurai besoin de
lui nicolas sarkozy fait mine de tendre
la main à ses rivaux mais cela ne fera
pas dévier alain juppé qui a bordeaux
plaidé une nouvelle fois pour des
primaires commune à la droite et au
centre
je vais sensible aux paroles aimables
guelleh à mon égard nous avons tous
besoin les uns des autres je pense que
la droite et le centre doivent se
rassembler pour
à redonner un espoir à la france dont
nous avons chacun à notre manière et
avec notre style et contribuer à des
primaires ouvertes inscrite dans les
statuts de l'ump auquel nicolas sarkozy
peut difficilement se soustraire sans
déclencher la colère de ses adversaires
ça s'appelle un coup d'état il ya un
collègue ya quelques mois à l'assemblée
qu'il ya des déceptions on s'en fout on
est là pour faire la politique
et là c'est à force de remarques de ce
type qu'on se trouve dans les tourments
que subit l'ump aujourd'hui mon objectif
c'est de rendre aux militants l'ump
l'honneur et le plaisir de militer
nicolas sarkozy a évité de répondre à
cette question des primaires
mais pour ses rivaux politiques il
n'existe pas d'homme providentiel pour
sauver l'ump mais des personnalités bien
décidé à affirmer leurs idées changez
pas changé et vous vous avez peut-être
me répondre d'une phrase mais ce que je
voudrais savoir c'est qu'à nicolas
sarkozy vous avez trouvé celui de 2007
celui de 2012 celui de 2010 7 points
d'interrogation d'abord dit que la
sarkozie et nicolas sarkozy est
évidemment le fait de se retirer du
pouvoir se retirait de la politique
pendant un temps fait réfléchir permet
de prendre du recul
je sais je
je défends vous vous le savez mon chiche
au président baré public il ya quelques
mois sur le pacte de responsabilité le
vote que
j'ai fait accompli c'est un acte en
faveur du plan valls
j'étais le seul député à ces critiques
et pour cela je les fais avec sincérité
pour les raisons que je vous ai expliqué
tout à l'heure et donc j'espère nous
espérons nous sommes beaucoup de
français a espéré que nicolas sarkozy a
compris qu'il faut dépasser les clivages
il l'a dit d'ailleurs à france 2 et je
vais vous dire pourquoi je je je
l'espère du plus profond de moi même
parce que je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
facilité ces deux choisir une droite
musclée qui gagnera contre une gauche
désorientés
est ce que la france gagnera est ce
qu'on sera en mesure de facile de les
changer notre pays durablement de
l'adapter dit que c'est une aujourd'hui
une erreur de reproduire ce qui
s'appelle à la même stratégie que ça
marche et ça vous dit mais vous savez je
crois que d'abord si l'élection
présidentielle a été perdu c'est par
définition qu'il ya eu des erreurs et je
pense notamment que la politique elle
doit se faire de manière extrêmement
équilibrée parce que nos compatriotes
sont à la recherche d'équilibré
collectif ce qui n'a pas su faire en
2002 mes deux jambes une droite une
jambe droite qui était bodybuildé et une
jambe gauche qui était atrophiée ça
n'était pas d'ailleurs la même situation
en 2007
donc il faut les deux jambes musclées la
jambe gauche mais il faut être
je pense plaint d' équilibre
passionnément l'équilibré mais ça veut
dire je rends je crois qu'il faut c'est
pour ça que c'est tout l'inversé de la
recherche d'un consensus tiède
c'est au contraire sur des valeurs être
extrêmement fort les défendre qui
peuvent être des valeurs de droite et
sur d'autres valeurs de générosité être
là aussi tout aussi fort et je crois que
c'est ce qu'attendent nos compatriotes
parce que nicolas sarkozy a dit quelque
chose que je partage quand il dit que
aujourd'hui
les partis politiques les les étiquettes
politiques les idéologies politiques
sont élimé je le pense profondément
avant de parler de lieu déloger rien
dans un instant juste une question comme
ça vous
nicolas sarkozy a visiblement décidé de
mettre en orbite ce la jeune garde entre
guillemets les gérald darmanin etc
mais que deviennent n'a envie de vous
demander les anciens compagnons de route
quand vous qui à la campagne qui se sont
investis vous savez je d'abord je pense
que c'est une formidable opportunité
une élection présidentielle la
préparation d'une élection
présidentielle pour faire naître de
nouveaux visages et je vais même vous
faire une confidence
moi comme je suis loin de notre pays et
que je regarde notre pays et que je le
compare à l'italie avec renzi vous avez
autre jeu j'ai pas honte mais je ne
compte pas les gants avec oui c'est moi
vous vous exprimez ce que je veux vous
exprimer avec cameron ou avec le
président obama
qu'est ce qui me frappe quand j'étais à
italie à new york et un grand
supermarché italien mais qui est presque
une honte ce qu'on pousse la porte on
arrive en italie et j'étais je prends un
café
j'ouvre la république à je vois renzi
entouré de tous les responsables de sa
formation politique que des jeunes parce
que aujourd'hui la jeunesse
ce n'est pas simplement c'est un bon
choix de faire appel à des jardins malin
mais il faut renouveler quand on voit
que par exemple ma famille politique
kiki et a été à donner un spectacle
absolument désolant je vous rappelle que
je n'ai soutenu ni jean françois copé ni
françois fillon et j'ai dénoncé ce
spectacle à tristan ma famille politique
elle elle a aujourd'hui besoin de
renouveau on a un bureau politique qui a
été désignée qui était en fait un yalta
entre les belligérants ne fait pas de
jeunes dans ce bureau politique et qui a
ensuite désigné un triumvirat avec eux
des anciens premiers ministres
- je crois aujourd'hui à la jeunesse et
cette semaine nicolas sarkozy était
aussi pour son premier meeting c'était
dans nord alors maire ça regardez ce
reportage de louis b nicolas sarkozy est
de retour et une boude pas son plaisir
si vous saviez comme je suis heureux de
retrouver premier meeting depuis la
présidentielle
il remonte sur le ring et attaque
d'emblée son ancien adversaire la
présidence dit normal on imagine ce que
cela aurait été s'il ne l'avait pas été
le comportement exemplaire des ministres
le président qui ne se mêlera pas de
tout la vie privée qui ne devra pas
interférer avec la vie publique
que reste-t-il de l'immense mois
résidant lui président de l'ump il veut
mettre fin à la crise de son parti
politique
en reprenant les rênes il promet qu'il
assumera son leadership avec autorité si
vous me choisissez comme président de
notre famille politique
j'assumerai mes responsabilités je
rassemblerai une équipe nouvelle
j'écouterai chacun nous débattrons de
façon approfondie aussi souvent qu'il le
faudra nous voterons et une fois la
décision prise
je veillerai à ce qu'elle soit appliquée
et respectée
assistanat immigration monde de
l'entreprise
l'ancien président à développer des
thématiques propres à son camp mais il a
aussi dévoilé quelques éléments de son
futur programme comme un référendum sur
le rsa les français devront donc être
consultées donner leur avis sur un
principe simple pas de rsa ou
d'allocation communal sans accepter en
contrepartie l'exercice d'une activité
au service de la collectivité pendant 55
minutes de discours nicolas sarkozy n'a
pas cité une seule fois l'ump préférant
parler de famille politique dans le
texte il a tendu la main à ses
adversaires fillon juppé et le maire
confirmant son attachement aux primaires
mais clairement ce soir il se présente
comme déjà vainqueur des élections
internes au parti
alors question simple le retour en
politique
est ce que ça marche c'est notre zoom de
la semaine
une question pour vous donner jean bart
bonjourbonjour notre éditorialiste
politique alors lé retour en politique
on sait ne réussissent pas tout c'est ce
que celui de nicolas sarkozy a réussi il
ya des retours qui ont fonctionné mais
pas de gens qui avaient été déjà élu
président de la république mitterrand
chirac ont eu des traversées du désert
c'est importantes et sont revenus le
seul président qui a essayé de revenir
ça a été valéry giscard d'estaing
bon moi je pense qu'on a réussi un
retour est là avec la perspective de la
présidentielle qu'en jouant sur les
trois piliers qui vous permet de
construire une élection le premier s'est
dirigé le parti dominant et de ce point
de vue nicolas sarkozy se trompe pas ils
essaient de prendre le contrôle de l'ump
qui rebaptisera peut-être mais voilà
ensuite il faut avoir le discours
dominant
alors j'ai bien entendu frédéric
lefebvre je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
encore il a peut-être la clé on attend
de voir comment il va muscler la jambe
gauche mais il faut avoir le discours
dominant
et le troisième point c'est au fond
avoir être dominant dans les items de
présidentialité alors il a un atout très
fort qui est toujours très déterminant
dans les élections présidentielles et
qui lui a permis à mon avis dans la
dernière campagne de limiter les dégâts
alors qu'il était parti de très loin
avec un très fort que j'ai c'est cette
espèce d'énergie de dynamisme et que
c'est toujours très important
est ce que ça ne suffira pas ça ne
suffira pas je pense que il faut qu'ils
donnent corps un nouveau projet crédible
et que ce retour n'apparaissent pas
simplement comme une revanche sur le
funeste destin à ses yeux d'un projet
pour l'instant frédéric lefebvre il ya
des grandes idées mais pour l'instant on
a plutôt l'impression d'avoir un
discours de la république et pas encore
sauvés du candidat le jeu revient ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure le drame de ma
famille politique depuis deux ans c'est
que personne ne travaille
c'est que tout le monde ne s'occupe que
de soi et ça a été le drame de la gauche
pendant les cinq ans pendant lesquels
nous gouvernons et c'est le drame de la
france politique c'est pas que je
fustige les fans et politiques rond
c'est c'est que je
moi je n'appartiens à aucun courant je
considère être une mauvaise chose
appartenait encore un peu car un peu
disparu quand je vous entends une
impression vous essayez de retrouver le
courant chababistes j'ai commencé ma vie
politique
c'est vrai que j'ai demandé à certains
mais vous savez je pense que il faut
essayer d'unir
voyez par exemple j'étais tout à l'heure
ce matin j'ai initié la fête de la
gastronomie
il ya il ya en 2011 c'est la quatrième
édition
j'étais aux côtés de la ministre tout à
l'heure on a lancé ensemble cette fête
de la gastronomie et pourquoi j'avais
voulu notamment à l'époque lancé cette
fête de la gastronomie
parce que ça fédère parce que la
gastronomie sa unis
quand je crois qu'il faut aujourd'hui
sortir d'un prix ce qui est partagé
fédérer qui ont regardé le thème tout
autant par la droite que par la gauche
qui est d'essayer de bâtir sur la
division moi je divisions internes dans
les familles politiques division vu
jouer on l'a vu dans son meeting
il faut bien que le dimanche soir sur
france 2 il a essayé d'être rassembleur
et on a retrouvé quand même dans ce
meeting le nicolas sarkozy très clivant
il a cette approche de la vie politique
alors on peut comprendre que dans un
premier temps il à la nécessité de
rassembler son temps pour gagner ce qui
serait à mon avis sans doute assez
facile la présidence de l'ump
mais là c'est la thur même de nicolas
sarkozy et clivante
oui en même temps c'est nicolas sarkozy
qui par exemple a fait l'ouverture c'est
nicolas sarkozy et dieu sait
qu'aujourd'hui on le voit c'est
important qui a voulu créer le conseil
du culte musulman en france c'est donc
c'est lui qui s'est battu pour
abandonner la double peine tout ça ça
date de ben je suis en train de dire que
ce qui me paraît essentiel pour nos
compatriotes qui considèrent que droite
gauche ne veut plus rien dire que les
hommes et les femmes politiques avant
tout que ce soit nicolas sarkozy que ce
soit l'actuel président de la république
françois hollande que ce soit chacun
d'entre nous dans nos familles
politiques que nous devons nous
concentrer sur l'essentiel qui est la
france et les français
les français souffrent dans la plupart
des pays que vous savez ça donne
beaucoup de recul de distance peut-être
de hauteur et vos clubs d'autres à
l'étranger souvent moi je vois tous mes
compatriotes qui vivent aux états unis
et au canada
croyez moi ils ont un regard amoureux
sur la france et en même temps ce regard
amoureux ici être critique et il voit à
quel point nous avons une capacité à
nous diviser
là où au contraire faut additionner vous
dire jury d'une phrase je préfère la
coalition à l'allemande que la
dissolution à la française s'est en même
temps le quart de la démocratie c'est
l'alternance et donc on peut pas tout
mettre dans le même pot si j'ose dire
non mais regardez de l'indicé allemand
mais mais mais c'est là le coeur d'une
élection présidentielle c'est la
capacité dans un camp de s'ouvrir à
l'autre tant pour rassembler le plus
largement belgique et c'est le coeur du
sujet qui est posé en face de la
question qui est posée aujourd'hui à
nicolas sarkozy et à votre famille
politique mais qui épouse et à la france
tout parce que vous parlez de votre
famille mais bien sûr mais je parle pas
que de ma famille politique je s'est
posé à tout le monde s'est posé tout
autant à la gauche qu'à la droite
message qui va avoir la capacité de dire
aux français je travaille pour vous je
ne travaille plus pour moi moi je
préfère mon pays à mon parti message
bien compris
merci de cet éclairage et on parle
justement de l'allemagne avec manuel
valls qui était à berlin pour rencontrer
la chancelière angela merkel qui a jugé
impressionnant
le programme de réformes du premier
ministre écoutez moi je veux dire aux
allemands que les réformes nous allons
les faire car c'est d'abord l'intérêt de
la france et malgré les difficultés la
france va faire les réformes pour elle
et pour le rock
et moi j'ai besoin aussi de la confiance
du peuple allemand
le premier ministre manuel valls a
présenté l'agenda des réformes et je
crois que la france entreprend une somme
impressionnante d'efforts selon moi ce
sont des réformes dans les domaines qui
vont au final décidé de la compétitivité
fredrik le fait que vous avez votés ce
pacte de responsabilité
présenté par manuel vals vous avez été
le seul député ump à le faire donc vous
applaudissez la politique de manuel
valls
non parce que j'ai dit à l'époque que je
considérais que d'abord c'était
insuffisant sur la réduction de la
dépense publique et j'ai dit aussi que
c'était insuffisant sur la relance de la
demande
parce que moi je crois qu'il faut
augmenter salaires directs des français
mais en baissant les charges les charges
salariales
les charges patronales donc je pense que
de manuela je vote parce que ça va dans
le sens de ce que je défends je vais pas
voter contre lui des mesures qui vont
dans le sens de ce que je défends est ce
que pour autant je considère que c'est
suffisant non et de la même façon vous
passez des images valsent merkel et en a
vu il ya eu d un moment une polémique où
on a expliqué que la france demandait un
certain nombre de choses à l'allemagne
mais moi je vais vous dire manuel valls
a raison
comme d'ailleurs le fmi comme beaucoup
de demander à l'allemagne la raison
d'avoir une politique de relance mais
madame merkel a raison de demander à la
france d'aller beaucoup plus loin sur
les réformes et sur la baisse de la
dépense publique parce que voyez vous je
crois et c'est là encore où on voit que
hollande ou manuel valls droite gauche
droite ces notions ne veulent pas dire
grand chose en l'occurrence c'est que
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut à la france et
j'ai un exemple à donner le canada un
premier ministre monsieur chrétien dans
les années 90 quand le canada était dans
la situation de la grèce et qu'il a
réduit drastiquement la dépense publique
ce corps perdu les plaques de glace et
impôts de baisser les chats iacono était
fort qui est fait je vous quand même
vous reconnaissez le courage de manuel
valls qui les fait les réformes ou telle
échelle tard chacun voit bien que sa
majorité
aujourd'hui est désorienté et c'est la
raison pour laquelle mais c'est la
raison pour laquelle quand je considère
que c'est bon pour la france je vote
tout ça vienne quand j'étais ministre
vous savez quand il y avait des
amendements socialistes ou communistes
quel est dans le bon sens sur un texte
que je défends des je les acceptais je
faisais pas le petit jeu habituel que
vous connaissez au parlement où surtout
on ne prend pas il en demande d'un
député
de sa famille politique de déposer le
même temps accepter aux députés ump mais
pas aux députés socialistes
je trouve ça ridicule dit stop stop à
cette façon de faire la politique c'est
ce qu'on disait un petit peu je pense
que c'est aujourd'hui ce qui est le plus
nuisible pour la france on va partir sur
un autre sujet sur les biens mardi
toujours le débat sur la famille est
relancé
jusqu'à présent les jugements rendus
étaient contradictoires il ya la cour de
cassation s'est prononcée elle a
autorisé l'adoption d'enfants nés à
l'étranger d'une pma explications et
réactions avec jean baptiste daoulas
l'avis de la cour de cassation met fin à
une incertitude
depuis la loi sur le mariage pour tous
les tribunaux français rendait des avis
contradictoires sur les demandes
d'adoption d'enfants nés par pma à
l'étranger certains couples de femmes
voyaient leurs demandes refusées
mais l'avis de la cour de cassation est
clair la pma à l'étranger n'est pas un
obstacle à l'adoption
la procréation médicalement assistée
reste donc interdite aux couples de
femmes dans les hôpitaux français
mais les pma réalisés à l'étranger sont
reconnues par le droit français
une situation qui gêne également les
partisans de la pma pour les couples de
femmes
ils voulaient l'autorisé des la loi sur
le mariage pour tous mais à l'époque le
gouvernement avait reculé face à la
manif pour tous il faudra bien qu'un
jour le législateur se décide à avoir un
petit peu de courage et à reconnaître
que c'est stupide d'obliger des femmes à
partir à l'étranger en belgique ou en
espagne pour une procréation
médicalement assistée
parce qu'après nous savons que ça pose
des problèmes juridiques qui sont qui
concerne directement l'enfant mais le
gouvernement n'est pas pressé de revenir
sur le dossier de la pma d'autant que la
manif pour tous ne désarment pas avec
une nouvelle manifestation prévue le 5
octobre contre la pma mais pas seulement
nous savions qu'il y avait le conseil
d'état claque qui doit rendre
prochainement un avis sur la circulaire
taubira il ya la rentrée scolaire avec
la question du genre et c'est donc il y
avait tout un ensemble d'éléments
d'événements qui faisait que c'était le
monde
de manifester les questions de société
seront omniprésentes en 2017
voilà les candidats de droite déjà
sommées de se positionner sur
l'abrogation de la loi taubira
alors les questions de société notamment
celle ci embarrasse on le voit votre
famille politique l'ump qui n'a pas une
position claire sur le sujet nicolas
sarkozy ne s'est pas prononcé lors de
son discours vous vous dites quoi quelle
est votre position notamment sur cette
question de la paix m
alors je avoir une position claire sur
un sujet comme celui là c'est très
compliqué moi j'ai écrit un dans mon
premier livre j'ai écrit un chapitre sur
cette question en partie et j'ai une
position d'ailleurs assez originale
entre guillemets dans ma famille
politique c'est que je crois à la
nécessité et j'ai défendu avec force
l'idée de l'union civile je raconte
d'ailleurs dans ce livre comment cette
idée et est venu et comment elle s'est
elle s'est construite et je pense que le
mariage et on l'a vu d'ailleurs
approfondie profondément divisé la
société française et j'étais certain que
cela diviserait profondément je donnais
même des témoignages d'ailleurs de
d'homosexuels qui me le disent eux-mêmes
en disant si vous faites le mariage vous
allez créer chez ma propre mère un
réflexe négatives sur les par mètre
carré et par an le paradoxe c'est que je
défendrai ce qui souvent sert d'argument
pour s'opposer au mariage
je défends dès l'adoption mais on
pourrait dire à vous entend pas ce qu'il
faut c'est pas qu'il aurait fallu
séparer les deux c'est encore une fois
très compliqué parce qu'on voit bien là
avec la décision de la cour de cassation
avec la question pma adoption tous ces
sujets sont extrêmement complexes et là
est ce que on ne prend pas le risque de
finalement de l'exploitation d'un
certain nombre de femmes qui seront
obligés de vendre leur corps doux et
leurs corps et dont il faut être
il faut faire très attention à ses
sujets mais je crois en tout cas et
c'est un bon exemple de faux débats sur
la question de l'adoption
à partir du moment où
un célibataire peut adopter par
définition un homosexuel peut adopter
et donc si ridicule de s'affronter une
fois la vègre partis politiques et j'ai
cette question très exclusive revient et
mayotte avec cela
cette question a été posée à tous les
parlementaires et à nicolas sarkozy
aussi si vous revenez au pouvoir faut-il
abroger ces lois encore une fois ça ne
veut rien dire
ah ben oui je la veux dire non on arrive
et on retire mais ça mais oui mais ça ne
veut rien dire que appartement où vous
avez une loi qui est appliquée qu'il ya
des mariages qui ont été célébrés donc
vous ne reviendrait pas sur cette armée
vous ne reviendrez pas je vous explique
à quel point tout ça est compliqué je
pense qu'il ya des éléments dans dans le
débat qu'ils font qu'aujourd'hui on a
une france qui est divisé c'est un point
que que je craignais d'ailleurs mais
mais qu'on n'imagine pas et donc
aujourd'hui je crois profondément
l'union civile avait un avantage et
pourrait avoir un avantage encore
aujourd'hui mais j'ai à la fois de
permettre à des couples homosexuels de
s'unir et je ne vois pas pourquoi on s'y
opposerait dans votre conviction
profonde d'un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes mais par contre ce serait
une erreur de toucher de revenir sur la
loi taubira qui donc adopté ce serait
une erreur je que que vous ayez une loi
comme cette comme si la loi dite taubira
qui sur des sujets sur lequel on le voit
d'ailleurs à droite comme à gauche a des
positions extrêmement divers si chacun
est sincère si chacun est sincère si on
sort des réflexes politiques
idéologiques si on essaye de ne pas dit
se dire que vont faire les gens les
électeurs les militants et qu'on essaye
simplement d'être sincère et bien je
crois qu'il ya pas de solution simple je
pense qu'il faut se remettre au travail
et trouver un bon équilibre
c'est sans doute le monde maître mot que
je réfléchisse a annoncé aujourd'hui on
passe à mercredi avec le choc et
l'effroi devant la barbarie la mort d'un
ressortissant français
exécuté au nom de l'état islamique il
est 17 heures ce jour-là la
représentation nationale siège quand la
nouvelle tombe en plein débat sur l'irak
hervé gourdet le français de 55 ans
assassiné par ses ravisseurs qui disent
agir en représailles au raid aérien
français thibault le floch alors que
l'exécution de l'otage hervé gronde elle
n'avait pas encore été confirmée
manuel valls tenait à rappeler la
fermeté du gouvernement français face
aux menaces proférées par les groupes
jihadistes si nous nous montrons faibles
face à cette menace nous encouragerons
ces lâches à poursuivre leur oeuvre de
mort nous ne faillirons pas et nous ne
tremblerons pas une détermination
partagée par les différents groupes
parlementaires
néanmoins certains orateurs comme le
député gdr françois à 106 souligne
d'isolement de la france seule avec les
états unis a bombardé les positions des
jihadistes en irak
oui il faut apporter une aide militaire
à ceux qui résistent aux jihadistes
ainsi qu'un soutien politique
humanitaire et économique
mais pas n'importe comment comment
pourrions-nous approuvé l'engagement
militaire de la france dans une
coalition sous la bannière américaine
dans laquelle manquent les acteurs
régionaux et aux luziens les plus
essentiels du côté de l'ump certains
députés regrettent que les bombardements
se limite à l'irak et qu'il ne fera pas
les bases arrières des terroristes situé
en syrie axel poniatowski par le même et
d'hypocrisie ne pas suivre sur la syrie
alors qu'on est engagée sur les frappes
aériennes
l'irakienne je trouve que c'est un peu
hypocrite où on y participe
complètement où on ne le fait pas mais
on ne le fait pas à moitié comme
monsieur hollande a décidé néanmoins les
mots qui reviennent le plus à la tribune
de la majorité à l'opposition ce sont
bien ceux d'unité nationale aujourd'hui
monsieur le premier ministre il n'y a
pas de droite il n'y a pas de centre il
n'y a pas de gauche
il ya la république face au terrorisme
le groupe
le groupe ump ne tergiverse pas il est
pour l'action et il est pour l'unité
nationale
si les frappes contre l'état islamique
se poursuivre jusqu'en janvier il y aura
de nouveau un débat au sein de
l'hémicycle
mais cette fois avec un vote des députés
alors les musulmans notamment de france
mobilise pour dire non à la barbarie
commise au nom de leur religion l'islam
vous dites bravo est ce qu'il ya un
risque aujourd'hui en france deux
fractures communautaire bien sûr qu'il
ya un risque
j'ai réagi moi un désir de fracture il
ya un risque de fracture
j'ai imaginé j'ai réagi immédiatement
face à cette décapitation monstrueuse
qui a choqué la france entière le monde
entier et j'ai réagi en disant il faut
de l'unité et il faut en même temps une
détermination totale à éradiquer le
terrorisme et les groupes terroristes
mais j'ai ajouté ça m'a valu d'ailleurs
sur twitter des réactions parfois
négative
j'ai rajouté mais pas d' amalgame alors
expliquez nous la salle mais tout
simplement parce qu'elle crée un risque
de fracture mais chacun d'entre nous en
tout cas c'est mon cas koné des français
musulmans extrêmement croyants qui pour
autant sont les plus fervents
détracteurs du terrorisme et de
l'islamisme et donc moi je
je souhaite que chacun ouvre les yeux
que on se rend bien compte que
aujourd'hui il ya des groupes
terroristes qui prennent la religion en
otage il préférait 10 millions de
sachets nous céder des jeunes français
qui sont capables de se fanatisés au
point de partir en jeu vous savez ma
réponse comment vous répondez
là encore pardonnez moi mais je vais
vous pouvez vous donner des exemples
quand j'étais à montréal il ya quelques
mois je rencontre des jeunes français
d'origine maghrébine qui venait des
quartiers nord de marseille du 93 qui
sont fiers d'être français qui sont
entrepreneurs et qui ont quitté la
france parce que dans notre pays il n'y
avait pas d'espoir regardez par exemple
qu'il ya un débat que je trouve
grotesque sur la fuite des cerveaux
tous les jeunes partent on entend ça
tous les jours l'histoire mieux que les
je vais non mais j'y viens parce que
c'est le sujet tant mieux que les jeunes
partent à la conquête du monde mais moi
ce que je veux c'est qu'il passe
simplement les jeunes des grandes écoles
pas simplement les jeunes des
universités que dans les quartiers
difficiles que dans les centres
d'apprentissage
on donne la possibilité aux jeunes
français de s'ouvrir d'aller voir le
monde parce que on ne peut pas laisser
des gens sans aucun secours et parce
qu'ensuite on rit sont les victimes vous
êtes un élu de se fier à les
instrumentaliser près avec laquelle vous
êtes un élu des français de l'étranger
ce que vous estimez que les français qui
sont à l'étranger aujourd'hui on court
un danger bien sûr dans ces zones
bien sûr d'abord par tous regardé et je
vais même vous dire les français qui
sont en france court un danger pour quoi
je parle d'unité mais parce que le
danger
il est pas simplement il faut comprendre
que cette guerre c'est une guerre pas
simplement comme je l'entends parfois
dont la france 2 ne devrait pas
s'occuper parce que elle s'occupe de la
situation d'un des pays arabes
qu'on les laisse eux-mêmes régler leurs
problèmes à l'étang des jeux uniquement
une question mais c'est aujourd'hui un
danger dans culturel non cultuelle mais
là encore le le danger aujourd'hui en
france il est surtout terroriste il ya
une menace réelle et quand je disais
tout à l'heure quand on ne peut pas
laisser dans la désespérance un certain
nombre de jeunes c'est que moi je ne
veux pas que des jeunes par leur
fragilité se retrouve embrigadé et c'est
là pourtant les peintures tout à l'heure
de fracture oui c'est ce risque de
reculer quand je vous ai cité l'exemple
du canada il existe bien sûr il en
existe mais il existe parce que
aujourd'hui on reproche beaucoup
à des jeunes de siffler la marseillaise
de ne pas aimer leur pays mais est ce
que nous nous les aimons c'est à dire
que c'est l'échec est ce que milou et c
est ce que nous nous leur envoyons ça
voulait dire mais je ne vais pas
héberger généralisée je dis qu'il ya un
certain nombre de gens des responsables
politiques des responsables
institutionnels des chefs d'entreprise
des français il ne faut pas les efforts
nécessaires qui n'ont qui en fait se
laisse envahir par leur peur alors que
moi je vois ailleurs dans le monde que
l' équilibre peut parfaitement exister à
partir du moment entre islam et valeurs
républicaines aujourd'hui vous voyez une
opposition mais bien les deux la même
façon mais mais écoutez on est dans un
pays
moi je suis catholique où je suis
pratiquant est ce que pour autant je ne
suis pas républicain j'ai c'est assez
amusant d'ailleurs parce que que ce soit
pour les fêtes juives ou pour les fêtes
catholiques il m'arrive de souhaiter à
mes compatriotes des voeux de bonheur et
je suis parfois attaquer d'ailleurs où
on dit mais on est dans un pays laïque
vous n'avez pas j'essaie une vision car
je trouve est rétrécie qui oppose les
gens qui divise les gens et de la même
façon que en politique je pense que
divisée est une erreur alors de la même
façon avec leur est divisée sur les
valeurs religieuses c'est une erreur
interne à l'avenir de la planète
il était attendu est enfin l'ordre du
jour à l'assemblée nationale sur le
projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique il a été examiné à
l'assemblée donc l'objectif lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique mais
aussi réduire la facture énergétique et
combattre le chômage par la croissance
verte fait avec le faire dans son
discours il revient encore une fois
nicolas sarkozy
excusez moi mais il se dit favorable à
l'expérimentation du gaz de schiste
alors qu'en tant que président il avait
dit non à l'expérimentation
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce que vous
aussi vous seriez favorable à cette
expérience elle même et bien sûr mais je
suis totalement favorable mais je vais
là encore il fait il faut regarder le
monde en face du principe de précaution
mais le camp sarkozyste soit le savez ce
que j'ai réalisé avec eric woerth
il ya quelques mois nous avons déposé
ensemble une proposition de loi pour
supprimer le principe de précaution
parce que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
là encore c'est un des textes je sais
jacques chirac il avait fait voter à
l'époque c'est un des textes qui empêche
notre pays de prendre des risques qui
empêche notre pays 2-2 d'être mondiale
d'être aux côtés de toutes les
démocraties la ville soyez environnement
attendre aux états unis mais faisons
faisant je dis pas qu'il faut faire tout
ce que font les états unis mais on peut
parfaitement aujourd'hui au contraire
soutenir la recherche
essayer de développer des moyens propres
non passibles de précaution les côtés
elle est d'accord non aux pratiques de
précaution oui au gaz de schiste non
principe de précaution ou gaz de schiste
bien sûr alors on va parler d'un autre
sujet si vous voulez bien devient un
phénomène qui nous vient encore une fois
des états unis veut bien passé aussi
pour nous en parler qui inquiète en
france
le plus de l'hebdo s'intéresse cette
semaine à netflix netflix qui fait peur
c'est un service de vidéo à la demande
par abonnement qui vient d'arriver en
france
est-ce que ça devrait tout révolutionner
opa en tout cas arrivera-t-il à concret
romo 1 10% des foyers français
c'est une autre question qu elle nous
répond simon barbarie se régale services
spéciaux politiciens véreux à la maison
blanche
l'image a fait le tour du monde elle est
extraite de la désormais célèbre série
house of cards véritables têtes de
gondoles et production du géant
américain netflix
voilà quinze jours que le site de vidéo
à la demande a débarqué en france est
première déception
house of cards n'est pas disponible dans
son catalogue canal+ qui a acheté les
droits continuent d'en avoir
l'exclusivité
le téléspectateur se détermine par
rapport à l'offre de programmes
la phrase au programme aujourd'hui nous
ne la connaissons pas et c'est là où la
bataille va faire rage entre les
opérateurs français et netflix
c'est sur l'offre de programmes parce
que finalement ce qui nous intéresse
c'est par les choses qu'on a envie de
regarder
fort de 50 millions d'abonnés dans le
monde le débarquement de netflix
bouscule la sacro-sainte exception
culturelle française
le champion de la vidéo en ligne ne sera
pas soumis aux quotas de 40% de films
français dans son répertoire ni aux
obligations d'investissement dans la
production hexagonale
son président fondateur ménage tout de
même son nouvel hôte européen avec l'
annonce d'une sorte de house of cards
sur la canebière en préparation une
future série intitulée marseille ce
n'est pas un site comme c'est une
comédie dramatique
un thriller politique avec des
interactions familiale et avec dan
franck le scénariste du film carlos nous
sommes très excités par le projet s'il
n'a pour le moment pas révolutionner le
marché
l'arrivée de netflix 2
sacré coup de vieux la réglementation
française et ses obligations de
financement et de diversité comment
imposer à un service de vidéo à la
demande d'un quota de fiction française
puisque l avenir ce sera bien le
téléspectateur qui aura le dernier mot
netflix c'est le coup de vieux à
l'exception culturelle française
c'est en tout cas l'obligation pour la
france d'évoluer dans son mode l
audiovisuel moi je les dis j'ai fait le
tour d'ailleurs d'un certain nombre de
grands patrons de chaînes j'ai été voir
le csa sur ces questions j'en ai parlé
avec l'ancien ministre de la culture
je pense qu'aujourd'hui vous dire là
encore les français qui sont à
l'étranger qui veut le voir les
programmes français sur internet
bein peuvent pas parce que nos chaînes
de télévision font de la géolocalisation
c'est mais je suis sûr d'une fleur
pellerin qui dit qu'il faut que le monde
change mais sinon notre modèle va tomber
on est très en retard mais on est très
en retard donc c'est lui qui en ouvrant
une ligne maginot
mais c'est une chance ici et pourquoi
c'est une chance parce que on est notre
exception culturelle fait que nous avons
aujourd'hui des industries culturelles
les plus dynamiques du monde entier mais
soyons là encore prenons des risques
on n'est pas assez d'actes pour nous aux
modèles d'aujourd'hui dans un monde où
la francophonie ne cesse regarder forbes
le magazine publié il ya quelques mois
une étude des américains des chercheurs
américains ont appliqué des modèles
économiques et démographiques sur la
réalité du monde d'aujourd'hui où on
parle français de horizon 2050 ils nous
disent ce sont ces français va être la
première langue du monde
mais soyons al partons à la conquête du
monde ne culpabilisons pas notre
jeunesse
soyons dynamique prenons des risques sur
notre culture on a une identité forte
c'est une chance la mondialisation c'est
l'uniformisation et nous on donne du
sens et bien soyons vainqueur et qu'il
est en confiance et qu'il dépassera les
prenons des risques c'est ce qu'on
retiendra peut-être que cette émission
merci merci à vous qu'a t on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine la semaine
prochaine après votre folle semaine
politique michael aéro d'élections
sénatoriales très bonne si le programme
sur la chaîne parlementaire et merci à
tous de votre fidélité